der Traum vom Eigenheim wird Ihnen
präsentiert von renovero für jedes
Projekt Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
renovero.ch dass mir da ja e Zukunft
machen das sch mega cool h so sie
[Musik]
gen noch
ich sag
[Musik]
no was der Architekt
Zeit ich w der RAS
best
grundsatzlich viel dass ne machen aber
dieah
schonfang mit dem Projekt
Hypo
a okay die absolute
[Musik]
Überforderung Ramona und rfael gehören
zu einer Minderheit in der Schweiz mit
31 Jahren können sich die Lehrerin unter
Unternehmensberater ihren großen Traum
vom eigenen Haus erfüllen
[Musik]
ja einersit ist natürlich sehr schön
gefreut
D und dass man Trum K verwirklich aber
natürlich Arbeit jetzt auf ein
Z ja also man h irgendwie GEF okay gut
hab und dann
so
hat schon bessere Tage
gesehen so
willkommen Ramona und rapael ziehen noch
nicht ein zuerst wollen sie das alte
Haus
renovieren ich fin Z der Eckbank noch
schön und wür jetzt irgendwie die wieder
integrier da ist oder nicht ja derhen
jetzt z. gar
nicht od z. der platt beim angsberich od
der finde ich auch schön die die Aussag
von der ramona ist mega schöne BTE und
ich gefunden zum Schachspiel ja aber im
H nicht
unbedingt ja und ich glaub man seht
wirklich relativ gut dass es da schon
recht eng ist also wenn sie jetzt machen
die Kind jetzt da
über obwohl da hatte wir jetzt
vielleicht sogar ich weiß nicht auf die
andere Seite de gemacht oder was nicht
auf die andere also so ne kontraintuitiv
wieso mach doch ke das ist doch nur in
England
so n das gerade
zeigen
so aber g die
die auf der gleich s das meine na aber
du
h
stimmt okay
Idee dass wir
da ja e Zukunft machen das finde ich das
sch mega cool das ganze halt K h
und Familie und halt ein irgendwie so
EAH so sie
genau ja ihr neues Zuhause steht im agau
im Heimatkanton der beiden ein Steinwurf
entfernt wohnt auch die Schwester von
Ramona
750000zaht ja inklusive Land und sind
703 Quadrat
74 ja
und Fläche von 30 quadr bis jetzt haben
wir alles sber finanziert also ein von
der Mantras von me
Vater kindheitimmer
fix ja ich glaub s beide sehr
sparsam und wir haben beide e relativ
gut Lohn so und die
Kombination
für
[Musik]
und das ist eigentlich fast brunstück
so
g ja und ist
riesig
cool
SP das war im
Winter der ST schon und das mirlich Mega
wichtigim kaufen oder beim beim Suche
von me Hus dass man Platz h ich Gefüh
das ist so in Zukunft immer wie
schwieriger wird sie zum Finden und
darum sind wir mega froh haben wir Dach
so viel
L auf ihrem Weg zum Eigenheim wird das
junge Paar von Rafaels Eltern
unterstützt ich hab zwei Geschwiester
und
Sie 100000 Frank für es Hus oder W oder
einfach Eigentum
zuaufen das ermöglich und wir jetzt
Glück dass wir für das wo jetzt da ST
hab nicht braucht ja das
war
gespannt das alte Haus ist zwar noch
nicht bewohnbar doch die beiden können
froh sein überhaupt eines bekommen zu
haben der Schweizer Immobilienmarkt ist
vollkommen
überhitzt
[Musik]
lu hier wohnt das Paar mit 1650 Franken
im Monat sind ihre Mietkosten
überschaubar also da
jetzt
Modell da
Resht sich um ihr Haus
imau
klar W natürlich aber DAF eigentlich
also ich nicht pressant da weg s jetzt
mal wir zah ja jetzt extrem wenig ze
also turum hab nichtessant wenn man
extrem viel zahlt und dann die
doppelbelastig H ist mit den schon
sicher schnau gar nicht so die Z und es
glanzt da find ich nicht so toll ja das
nicht
unbedingt was der sich
fr Holz oder
nicht das eine von Frage also so Moment
denk die geh so z
t also es geht schon immer h und tief
jetzt W ich sageneder h
aberon so nicht denke kommt so viel
Arbeit du zu und also es ist ja auch
schön also die Sache die MA ich zum Teil
ger aber ich glaube me der viel
[Musik]
weren digitale Beratungsagentur
Luzern hier arbeitet rapael zusammen mit
dem Firmeninhaber Klaus Oberholzer
die beiden unterstützen Kunden die den
Umsatz ihr onlinefmen steigern wollen
die sind nicht ganz genau
aber linksp
[Gelächter]
rechts du groß
werchrieben 80jährige Bünz im kper von
30jährig sogar cool gefunden mag ich
mich erinneren ja ich fr mich immer was
ist so
schlecht alle du h alles was du was du
brauchst zum zum Glück wenn D man dasus
bauen D man Familie
hab shaft werden und so das finde ich
find ich
großartig
du mitat g h was du
mit und D ein nach dem andere
checklarbeck
Extrem
[Musik]
wiersprochen der erste Termin mit Ihrem
Architekten
an die neuhausbesitzer nehmen den
öffentlichen Verkehr Auto haben sie
keines
smbard de so
sag mit Idee und Sachen wo man gut
findet ja das sind alles Bilder W g und
das sind Bilder wo g hab wir üchniedig
aber das da so schmine
wrumtrennergendwin fest
hot das Dunkel aber
so
Co gut also ich kein Plan jetzt
bildesucht
aber ich w nicht
machen und ich sehr gespannt was jetzt
zum
also findet ja
ne das oder Sachen und anders machen bin
sehr gespannt
DAU
ich
Hall für die Suche nach dem geeigneten
Architekten haben Sie sich Zeit genommen
es war ihnen wichtig dass er Ihre
individuellen Bedürfnisse berücksichtigt
noch sind Sie sich unsicher ob sie das
Haus renovieren oder abreißen und ein
neues Haus bauen sollen
halloall eren
mal super wter
ja
perfektell
das
Okay ja das ist
Grund
relativ schmal
urspr aufm
und hab mal gerechnet und hab das Gefühl
neau müss wir jetzt gich mal ne Betracht
Z dass man Dasch dachesch übernimmt das
ist kein
Thema
jaäig sicher gich h das umba das Mus
alles
machen ja mir noch wichtig was du ja
nein das ist mein da machst quasi Neubau
das
wichtig
ja also ich w sagen der rasem ist best
dem
Hus das einzige funktioniert
WS ist
okay ne ich
mE ja mehr oder weniger klar so gut das
Hal kann
Renovation oder Neubau eine schwierige
Entscheidung die Tage des alten Hauses
im agau scheinen
[Musik]
gezählt in ihrer Mietwohnung in Luzern
brüten Ramona und rfael über den
Bauplänen also das ist überle W
[Musik]
also gemacht wenn
du
also V der Bewer von der Bank gich WT
wenn du gich Geld
investierst immer also grundsätzlich R
viel dass man ne machen aber die zah das
mus sagen meine so steh ist klar ja
Neubau macht mehr Sinn einfach
wirtschaftlich aber Situation
wennbau gemacht relativ gut könen
leisten und jetzt wenn wir ein Neubau
machen den haben wir es den schon FG
nachher also wir mal durchn Kön es
finanzieren knapp aber
es ist den so ja dann ist den vi also
nicht trotz des finanziellen Risikos
entscheiden sich die beiden anfangs3er
für einen
Neubau zusammen mit dem Architekten
machen Sie sich jetzt an die Planung
ich glaub als erst würde ich mal ne
soramm versuchen festlecken also
grundsätzlich g V V programmus das heißt
wie viel ja was für Zimmer W ihr wie
groß sind dir
das nicht so genauleit nein
das nicht also was ich mir nur überleid
was viicht Thema W W mittel bis
langfristig g Gästezimmer wenn jetzt dus
D mal zwei Kinder geht
den sind nacher mit dem Büro Z
Kinderzimmer Schlafzimmer Zim am
Limit
zimef im
[Musik]
[Applaus]
OG und dann ist
frag was passiert im
untergescho so ist das für euch das
Thema dass man seit untergescho tut
minimieren males BG definiert festleit
so ungefähr 800
so und aber ich habit muss m sich
was also ich sage immeril kostet 1
Million und 800000 ist halt schon
kriingensbudget also oder entweder baut
einfach böchli so mit UG der wird das
irgendwi be oder man baut irgendwas
speziells ich hätte uch was speziells
Bau weiß nicht wie es Euch Gott und da
muss man irgendwo wie
Kompromiss das alte Häuschen wird also
definitiv einem Neubau weichen
müssen um sich diesen leisten zu können
muss das junge Paar viel Geld
sparen sogar schon im Kindergarten h
mamfangen als pro Woche irgendwie Z RA
20 Rappe also mega wenig aber so haben
wir wir ja was machen wir jetzt mit dem
Geld und W man jetzt wirklich die
Süßigkeit oder lieber sparen und bis
größer kaufen und ja ich B mega dankbar
ist so ja jetzt hab ich e nicht so
Problem ja mit dem Geld um mit nur 33
Jahren schafften es die Doppelverdiener
Eigenkapital von 400000 die
se seit sie eine Neubau planen führt
rfael eine Excelliste um die Kosten im
Griff zu behalten du immer so Gefühl ja
wenn jetzt mus sparen auf ir okay D
jetzt beim ich dass man viicht die
günstiger varianteen V dem und S genau
nicht die Sache wirklich sondern es kom
viel
meend
z. oder der Hypothek machen wirklich
Gefühl wo sind die wo man wirklich dasf
das H
me ja Ries Investition frü und haben wir
m sicher sie bevor wir jetzt da Hal wier
machen mit dem Projekt D leisten das ist
H aber B jetzt
gut soar weniger Geld gehus budgtier
kan zurück im Kanton Ager um einen
umfassenderen Eindruck vom Werk des
Architekten zu bekommen besichtigen
Ramona und Rafael ein Haus das Karol
Ecker für eine holländische Familie
gebaut hat alles gut ja ja ja
super ja schön h wir das mal
alle se h r ja mega to GU Job gemacht
stke ist nicht ganz Absturz sicher stim
wir hab unchrieben nichts passiert jetzt
bitte ja und das ist schmine wo den da
das chig über g da okay
schön schon spannend am Anfang auch mit
das Beton und sicher auch die Wand ich
weiß noch dass ich auch gesagt hab von
oh so viele Löcher mus die nicht
zumachen oder man ja ich find die fast
die schönste ja ist auch
schön schön man gewöhnt sich daran das
ist ja es ist V ist es so fast normaal
und
warm mega toll mit der hö
schie sehr
schön wowol sehr schön ich freue
mich ich bin so froh hab dich
glaut sind am Anfang aber ja freue mich
sehr best mich schon ja also das nicht
so schn schn gangenen Architekt
Architektin finde wo man sichf Verl das
mehrheitlich gut und die zammenarbeit
funktioniert eineinhalb Monate später
präsentiert Karol Ecker in seinem
Architekturbüro in Luzern die ersten
Entwürfe also Tür auf g da inen aber es
gibt jetzt rümlich Gefühl oder da inlich
da
ste und dann so
Verbindig so fürstell rumtrenner und da
vorne öffnet sich der Gang so Licht noch
hinter mal
da genau DAH hin wird re dass ich wie
das Badzimmer und dann da ist groß
Schlafzimmer mega toll ja sehr
interessant ich weiß wie nicht also ich
find mega toll aber wenn ich jetzt beim
budg überlege dann g mir ja relativ budg
auch für Fassade oder für PUs oder für
pister also iche ke
einfach Kopf und dann überlegmer wie wir
kompak ja einfach
dafürendwi
immer noch das Thema wir sparen
200 die Variante noch nicht so ganz
fertigant aber mal was machen mit dem
total kompakte
Volumen Punkt wie jetzt einige W
Bauwand
Norm ich
zumindest
ich
normal klar es muss e
gefallen aber am Schluss l primär ja
also es ist sch
was ich bin nicht der W se Familie
Schublade zieht und das so Bau das ja
aber aber wenn du sag noch genau
das dann muss man da kreativ da muss man
einfach planen und mus führen das ist
klar
ja ja ich bin ich nicht so schnau
[Gelächter]
Entscheid cool ja ist
coolt immer ist klar V
allemil einmal und das das ist klar dass
manach so viel Idee im Kopf hat und
irgendwie alles W ja meistens BU sch bis
man dann
B Finale Grundriss ist aber oft oft
landet man d ungef
Wiederfang die erste Begeisterung ist
verflogen die Planung entpuppt sich als
nervenaufreibende
Sache auch Monate später steht das Haus
im argau noch immer
[Musik]
Hypothekarzinsen und Preise für
Baumaterialien steigen ohne
Ende es scheint der ungünstigste
Zeitpunkt zu sein um mit knappen Budget
ein Haus bauen zu
wollen
und Budget hab wir B mal schn Pause
braucht und die Pause einach braucht so
dass mir fre nicht
verlre ja es ist schon
ein mus schon mal mirfang mit dem
Projekt so h
hypothekar und
wenn Hypothek rechnisch mit den beträg
wo wir brauchen für zum neues Hus bauen
den sind das mehrere000 Frank da h oder
einfach nicht h ja und wir wer halt
wirklich mit dem H schlussendlich selber
in finanziellrieben also es ist wirklich
relativ einfache Geschicht als wir
machen das nur wenn wir auch sicher sind
dass wir das können finanzieren und dass
das am Schluss
funktioniert
[Musik]
lu rapael hat ein preiswertes Hobby er
jogt gerne mit einem Ziel vor Augen die
Teilnahme am Swiss City
halbmarathonim Halbmarathon weiß
ziemlich genau was die das ist der
Vorteil weiß wie lang mus weiß
wast und das ist beim h so D Gefühl du
weß was
kom Zeit das machen das und dann geht
den B am Schluss ganz anderen Ort
[Musik]
dfang Z
und
[Applaus]
rfael beweist dass er Ausdauer hat einen
langen Atem braucht er auch bei seinem
Traum vom
Eigenheim die Planung zieht sich seit
einem halben Jahr schleppend
[Musik]
dahin, Halbmarathons schafft er in einer
Stunde 53 Minuten unter dem angestrebten
Ziel von 2
Stunden das Haus im argau steht auch ein
Jahr nach dem Kauf noch unbewohnt und
verlassen
da die Situation auf dem Baumarkt hat
sich weiter verschärft Energiekrise und
Teuerung treiben die Kosten weiter in
die
Höhe
[Musik]
sind ne
Jes tatslich die letzte
let materiale
sind untereh
L buiness d Ich und sieag das
ist nochlebt was hat einfach tut den
ganz du h kein Mehrwert dafür also es
ist einfach es K einfach mehr und du kan
gich wie die Z
jah den aber für
dich unfair das ganze nein es ist also
de es tut wirklich we so aber auf die
andere Seite m ja schon sag sind
wirklich luxusprem alsoade die jzige
Situation wieso
überhaupt W ich den jetzt da auf drücken
also ist immer noch mega Luxus D Haup
Kön Sache reden und ja ja das ist ich
würde das behaupt für Million bauen also
we mit densprü H mit de Flächen also
meine doch einige Quadrat zum W oder da
gibt irgendwo Möglichkeit zum Fläche
hergeen ich wür mal sagen wir gehen in
Ruhe die Liste l wo man noch
reduzieren Zitrone
noch ganz h we natürlich
lös ist genau das jetzt SMer du muss
jeder Position sparen oder du
sag undf machen
was
ich fin
Grund
schön
okay also ich hab
Gefühl wenn wir jetzt das noch sopassen
dass wir die Sache da noch besprochen
hab vielleicht
noch V Volumen Grund
kompromittieren
da auf vernünftige Zahl we es G F nie so
super vorbereitet zur Bank du das
Ding ja mir W lieber wenn wir zu Bank
geh nach sagen bra jetzt doch
nicht ja sind den mit derätz zu der Bank
und
dann ja z Bank
wofunden ja das ist finanzierbar und
dann istum Gang Kondition den jetzt
diskutieren alles zammen haben wir 1,2
Millionen aufgenommen was immer noch
recht absurd DT wenn man das so seit es
ist genug wir hab schon ausgerechnet wie
dass wir das möglich bal
wi zurückzahlen dass nicht so Höch
verschuldet
sind eineinhalb Jahre nach dem Kauf ist
die Planung fast abgeschlossen der
Neubau finanziert und das Budget n doch
höher als eine Million
Franken Ramona und rfael suchen sich
eine Küche
aus das Paar hat einen Grund mehr ein
Haus zu
bauen ja ramona ist schwanger das heißt
wir haben ein Kinderzimmer schon
maletzt und
ja
gesehen das heißt alles vorbereitet
FT noch und
wenn Baum
pflanzen alles gemacht was
mus
Standard sch
beschicht und diind echtol
gen die sind wirklich echt aber das
das ja
das immer
ne alles
gut ja das wir ganz
anders ze ich find Hal einfach so die
dünklere Tön gefallen mir tenziell
besser Ramona find die hellere schöner
das ist so grundleg die Diskussion wo
wir immer hab eine den das Gott hat
eigentlich
alles die absolute
überforder jetzt die kom oder die schön
was also ich meine wir sind immer nur
uneinig DAH nichtert aber meistens Sie
sich einfach am Schluss durgesetzt das
stimmt
nicht das stimmt
nichtil ja wie der große Detail
nicht im Sommer sind die Bauprofile
erstellt und das Gesuch
eingereicht jetzt müssen Sie warten bis
die Gemeinde grünes Licht
[Musik]
gibt auf einer Alp im Berner Oberland
genießen Rafael und Ramona Ferien
zusammen mit ihrer Familie sie sind
jetzt zu
dritt
[Gelächter]
super sehr
schön was ist das da für
[Musik]
ein gut jetzt also derft mega
gut
besseru mega viel gofen wir haben recht
viel einfach gewartet wirklich jetzt so
wir haben BA schon Monat nichtereicht
und immer wiederzöger geh und das noch
reich
machen ST immer
noch die unendliche Geschichte ramona
ist als jüngstes von insgesamt sechs
Kindern aufgewachsen ja sie schaut Imam
habe ich geseh
[Musik]
frü Studium
oder
das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit
seit ihrer Jugend steht für Ramona und
Rafael der Traum vom Eigenheim im
Zentrum ein langer Weg mit vielen
Hindernissen
zum
leitchir ja ja vi
nicht
Reiz dufst zü nicht machen ja hallo das
ist ein extrem Sportart extrem sportar
gleitschirmüge
[Musik]
nein
sa noch während der Ferien auf der Alp
wird ihr Baugesuch publiziert nach einem
Monat ist klar es gibt keine
Einsprachen jetzt fehlt nur noch die
Baubewilligung ein weiterer Termin beim
Architekten steht
an
und schnell
Bild der
fade so soll es aussehen Ramonas und
rapaels
Traumhaus ist punktus SN elus das ist
schon mal super na ich fin doch noch ich
find sehr spannend ich fin tut sich
schön die und Moment find ich sehr sehr
schön auch in
natürlich
[Musik]
Bild
gemacht diese Bilder sehen die beiden
zum ersten
mal so eine Platz
visualisiert
machen
ja ganze h
visualisiert
[Musik]
wow
cool wenn man das so visualisiert hätte
kann man sichfach noch mal besser
vorstellen ja einiges cool auf der
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Plan ne normaler s mir wirklich bekannt
dafür dass wir schnell sind das ist
echtor Norm sehr zügig
unterwegs
du ich glaub also ihr sind also aber
wenn ich mit anderen verglich nicht so
dass mir extrem lang me V
nullfang rückblickend betrachtet war die
größte Herausforderung die Finanzierung
in derart schwierigen
Zeiten also die Unsicherheit wie
entwickelt sich jetzt alles und auch den
Diskussionen mit der
Ban wen nein das finanzieren nicht sch
so Moment wo ja wo ich den Hal zwielt
dass das vernünftig ist das ist bei mir
so Thema darum
bin Teil könen fixen und das ist jetzt
auch Gang z.B ohne
PK das ist W beid nicht woh wenn
PK die braen
[Musik]
Zukunft Jahre ist es nun her seit sie
das alte Haus im argau gekauft haben
bald soll es abgerissen werden die junge
Familie wünscht sich an Weihnachten 2024
einzuziehen in einem der umstrittensten
Punkte hat sich Ramona
[Musik]
durchgesetzt
sch der
Wasserstand
stromblass es wird also wieder einen
Keller
geben
verständich
gut jetzt ja
sich sch
abgel
hervorragen trotz aller Widrigkeiten sie
bereuen ihre Entscheidung für einen
Abriss nicht im geringsten das
ist dies da also ich freue mich einfach
me also meine muss ehrlich
sagen jetzt nicht me
so also me her allech
W
macht und
[Gelächter]
soch bauen und da haben wir niemals Dank
dass es z Jahr Gott also dass wir noch
zi Jahr da stehen und genau g
da okay also wir könen freu aufs
bevorstehende Projekt und aufs Hus wo
mir mitgestaltet hab und das schon auch
schön ja
ma
ja ees Labisch einiges anders W
zwischen
[Musik]
legendär Ramona und Rafaels Weg zum
Eigenheim lang und
beschwerlich aber auch volollle Hoffnung
und Vorfreude auf ihr eigenes
[Musik]
Zuhause der Traum vom Eigenheim wurde
Ihnen präsentiert von renovero für jedes
Projekt Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
renovero.ca